welcome to the introduction for the
rayman behind the scenes video i'm sam
and i'm nico and we're here to tell you
how we made it or actually
just kind of show you what happened when
we shot it
yeah we got some good stuff here because
we're showing off new rigs the camera a
lot of cool stunts and how we approach
i guess showing you guys how you
approach like writing and structuring a
shoot so that it goes
without any go smoothly without any
problems i can't talk very well right
now and we're also teaching you how to
get a kid in your video and have them
act well you'll see you'll see more
about that later yeah so that first time
active kids they always say don't direct
kids or animals
we did animals with kittens on the beach
easy
well time consuming
and now i finally have a kid in a video
a lot easier than cats actually
mostly the saying is true though
so we're going to get ready to shoot
this first we got to get everybody in
the costume
we gotta get everybody in the makeup
and while it's happening i'm gonna go to
location with our stunt coordinator eric
linden i'm gonna walk through all the
shots and kind of figure it out
then i'll probably come back and sit
around for a while while people finish
getting put into costume and makeup
and we start shooting i'm trista a
makeup artist and for this shoot we
painted the stunt guys green and brown
so they look more like these ogre
characters in the
in the video game
and i used like alcohol-based makeup and
airbrushed them so it pretty much lasts
all day and with minimal touch-ups since
they're going to be running around and
flying through the air and stuff like
that what's up guys i'm eric linden with
action factory and we're here on tugger
ranch filming uh rayman for uh for
corridor digital uh me and the action
factory team have done a lot of stuff
with corridor at this point see we've
done uh shock troopers was our first
endeavor where people are flying through
the air we've done first person third
person just a gravity gun with corridor
digital today we're doing a little thing
with uh rayman our digital character and
barbara
who's going to be willing a giant battle
axe
so we have some stunt guys out here
today that are going to take some sweet
falls uh we might get into little air
ram work where we have a hydraulic that
launches people through the air
and uh some just good and down dirty uh
battle stuff when planning out a shoot
like any type of shoot it always comes
in like stages and layers and stuff like
that you always start with like the most
simple idea and eventually you end up
with this very refined complex thing
where you're organizing a dozen people
all around on set for this video in
particular
the
first part of this idea was basically
all right we're taking this game
character and setting an entire like
action sequence to music we don't even
know what's going to happen yet and
basically from there we just start
elaborating you do the next pass where
it's like who's actually going to be in
the video all right these characters
these characters uh what are they going
to look like this this put the costumes
on and basically just keep going through
these little steps so you know from step
one
you know like there's
you almost have no idea what the final
product is exactly gonna be like i mean
you have a some sort of imaginary kind
of vision of what it can end up like
but the process is something that
definitely takes time and energy and
effort kind of building your way all the
way there
for our shoots we typically don't write
scripts when people see like a script
you know the courier font you know all
this formatting stuff we actually rarely
use that we only use that when we need
to be very formalized when we're maybe
pitching projects or trying to get like
professional actors to work with us
but when it's just us sometimes we don't
even have an outline it's just like a
shot list or the other way around
sometimes you only have an outline
because niko and myself are usually the
only people who really have to worry
about that stuff it's very informal
sometimes it's just like a google doc or
something like that but typically
outlines and shot lists are what we
primarily use outlines just so we can
explain what it's about to everyone and
then a shot list for ourselves so we
know each individual setup that we have
to do that day
so this piece is set to a song
and it's really really integrated into
it and in order to come up with
where all the hits happen where all the
cuts happen how many cuts i even have
um i made something we call it a video
board there's a couple different ways
you can go about doing this kind of
stuff in this case what i made it was a
sequence of just colored frames and just
cuts for each time we have a cut in real
life and i just have text describing
what's happening in occasion i'll have a
flash to emphasize a beat that happens
within the shot so after making an edit
which is just literally just cutting
through colored shots to the beat with
some flashes i then had an idea of how
many
beats i had for this part of the fight
scene or for this little dialogue scene
or
for this little setup and it was from
there that i could go on to actually
make the piece
i'm using this viewfinder so i can plan
my shots
without having to use the camera we go
with the pirate theme that could be uh
it looks like a knife machete
so as you guys probably know we play a
lot of airsoft and we actually found
that the the dump pouches where you
throw all your mags and you're playing
airsoft they work great for like utility
bags on set so like i'll keep a wireless
monitor in here like right now i've got
my
radio and
a viewfinder
probably throw my ipad in there so yeah
uh they're super handy as you guys know
we get all our stuff from evike so
ebike.com airsoft stuff
sometimes when framing people up like
you're trying to essentially focus
people's attention on the center of
action and a lot of people like to frame
dialogue or certain shots like with
these really artistic you know angles
like the guy's like way off to the left
and the whole frames empty and stuff
like that and while they can kind of
look good at first if you if you draw
people's eyes too far to the edge of the
frame it starts becoming very
distracting of people because their
field of vision is no longer surrounded
by the image itself there's it's
partially the image and then whatever's
next to the screen which is not part of
your story you know that's their living
room or blackness in a theater and so
you always want to make sure you're not
forcing people's center of attention in
their eye too far off the screen because
it starts becoming either annoying
distracting and for some people even
like disorienting or painful to watch
i'm gonna be right here
close up on your left shoulder okay
you guys are walking
and brandon you're gonna look over your
shoulder you're gonna see okay rayman
and barbara over there and you're
basically gonna be scaling at them like
you're doing now it's just like
hey i'm lily fuller i'm playing barbara
and today we're shooting a promo video
for raymond legends the new raymond
legends for wii um and i'm swinging this
axe round and killing a lot of pirates
it's no big deal yeah
all right so
getting through the day it's getting a
little bit late we're not
super behind scheduled but we are a
little bit so we need to accelerate just
a little bit here so we're being
strategic and having eric here playing
through the next shot with the actress
get it all figured out get all the stunt
stuff set up i'm gonna take another
stunt guy and i'm gonna go shoot another
sequence that doesn't require too much
stuff so we're basically going to split
up here multitask and then come back
together and that should get us back on
schedule since it's
so for the rayman
digital character
more than likely i'm going to be
standing in for that character and i'll
i'll be mimicking the movements that
he's going to portray outside of like my
arm actually stretching and i'll be used
as a template for the stunt guys to run
in on certain timings and take the
reactions and then we'll do a take where
i'm literally not there and they do the
exact same movement and then
corridor works the magic and there's
rayman all right so there's a lot of
different techniques you can use to get
stun guy in the air you can just jump
you can hop off a trampoline or you can
use an air ram and think about narrow
ramp
is it requires a certain approach you
can't just necessarily stand on it and
do something if you do it'll it'll look
kind of all right we have a specific bit
of choreography here where
barbara ducks and like chambers her
swing
and the next shot hits the guy in the
back and keeps flying like
this as the x hits in the back of the
head so that's what they're setting up
to do right here and so we can get a
really cool shot with a ton of there
and it'll look super epic and like she's
super powerful so that's what we're
doing now so when doing slow motion
shots we've kind of started just using
the phrase a 300 shot simply because
almost all slow motion shots you see
nowadays are
in the movie 300. there's like a couple
types that you see over and over again
um one particular is the
classic like speed ramp
like fighting midair shot we've actually
done a bunch of those in multiple videos
uh most recently was our zelda video we
opened a
fight sequence with the swords with
essentially a 300 shot where a guy runs
up jumps into speed rams hit with him
posing with a sword
technically
i think that's
more like troy
yeah opening troy yeah but
you know that's
inspired by 300. so whatever
but um basically uh in the sequence okay
we're doing the same thing here
it's it works really well when doing
fights because it helps establish a
rhythm and you can force the rhythm
because you're speed ramping and
choosing the points you want to
emphasize so
that is where we are doing our 300 shot
action
for those of you guys who watch our
channel you know that we like to shoot a
lot of things handheld
in this case we're shooting with an epic
today that we uh
rented from our friend arthur i was
shooting it handheld and uh
when people are shooting with cinematic
digital cameras like this they like to
load them up with a ton of stuff and i
understand why if you're on a big movie
shoot you have all this different
equipment you need to work with but
we're just a couple guys running around
in the woods so we're all about light
handheld setups let's just get really
nice shots let's set up things be a
one-man crew i can pull focus just fine
with a single hand
and really what it all comes down to for
a setup like this is eliminating as much
weight as possible and the thing that
puts a lot of weight on the camera is
the battery so today i'm trying out the
red battery belt clip running the
battery here and just the cable to the
camera i also have another cable here
which will eventually be velcroed on
which is for our wireless monitor so i
have all that stuff just sitting on my
hip and then the camera is just the bare
minimum camera body and lens and screen
and a couple handles to get all my shots
so the character you just saw he's the
boss the boss live at stone um
are there boss livid stones in the game
probably i don't know burger taking some
creative liberties uh
he's got a better jacket than everybody
else he's got a cooler feather than
everybody else he also rages out way
harder because he
can attack and hurt more people without
dying than anybody else so
he's uh he just made his entrance
and we're gonna see what happens to them
in the rest of the piece
kids
what are they
working with kids how do you do it and
honestly we're kind of improvising here
we don't do it much we don't know much
about it but i think
after kind of talking with them you know
like kids are
they they want to play they want to have
they want attention you know they have
tons of energy it's like how do you get
them to focus that on a scene um you
can't tell them like imaginary things
you can't say oh there's supposed to be
a guy over there or there's a cg
character here or
you know you're thinking this feeling
you know it's like it's all about the
physicality of it so it's like if you
want a kid to make an expression you
need to actually work with you know
their facial expressions and actually
say oh
make this kind of face like you've
you're seeing
you know a toy like i i told him an
example like make a surprise or like
what face would you make if you saw
optimus prime in real life and he was
like oh
and the only reason i mentioned that is
because he was actually playing with
transformers toys earlier so it's
something he could actually physically
relate to that he actually
had experience with that we just we were
playing games of copycat i was behind
the camera actually i said all right
copy me and so i do these moves and he'd
copy me and he's actually basing it off
of something physical real in front of
him and um that definitely works because
you know he's he's actually basing it
off of something that is there to
interact with you know not an imaginary
uh idea i guess right now i'm trying to
figure out is blocking and blocking is
where you figure out where people's
positions are going to be
so i know the basic actions i even have
the shots generally figured out like
this is a close-up this is a wide etc
but what i don't know is now that we're
in the environment is where everybody's
going to be
so now i'm sitting here thinking maybe
the boss should be up there and rayman
and barbara will be over there or maybe
the boss should be over there and they
should be here and i'm looking at the
backgrounds and what might happen with
when the camera is here versus there or
wondering if i should even just straight
up flip them and put them on other sides
so it's a lot of question of do i want
people running left to right right to
left do i want this in the background do
i want that in the background
and generally speaking
you know you look at things like right
i'm right here and i see this row of
trees
this straw of trees looks kind of pretty
and the trees behind it look kind of
pretty so that's gonna make a nice
background so i'm starting with that as
a starting point this is a nice
background now the question is
is the enemy is the boss gonna be down
there
or is it gonna be right here and the
characters are gonna be down there
and so
the best thing you can do when you're in
like these kind of like brain teaser
puzzles
is just position things and start like
don't start shooting just start planning
and like start setting stuff up
and then once you kind of start that
it'll start to really clarify and then
it's easy to see if you need to make
changes what's going to happen is hitler
is going to take a hit on the ground
he's going to flop around like a dead
bad guy
it's going to be great
that's the end of those grueling two
days they actually weren't that grueling
it's a lot of fun yeah it was a lemon
farm where jake and me learn to eat
lemons so now we basically have a week
to do all our post-production to edit
and do all the visual effects sound
music the whole shebang if you guys are
probably a little familiar with that if
you followed any of other of our
behind-the-scenes videos
yeah a few years ago we made a movie
called dark island and after that i i
made a personal vow to never have a cg
character in a video ever again uh and i
guess we broke it so now we have to do
all the effects on this piece this could
be
really fun it's gonna turn out great
though i can't wait so you guys thanks
for watching and uh free to check out
the video if you haven't yet on our main
channel and follow us on twitter if you
want to ask us questions about stuff
and
watch our show lan party if you like
video games yeah download jewelry and
play with us
yeah we have a server it's it's really
fun we tweet out when we play so you'll
see it yeah all right laters